black holes are the gravitational
monsters of the universe they are so
powerful that nothing not even light can
escape their grasp one black hole is bad
enough but if you took two black holes
and smashed them into each other they'd
be capable of changing the shape of
space itself how would an ting with that
explosion be and could it somehow reach
earth this is what if and here's what
would happen if two black holes collided
of course we have no means to capture or
control black holes yet so imagine
you're observing one from a giant
telescope here on earth and suddenly you
notice something strange is that another
black hole it sure looks like it and it
also looks like these two are about to
collide it turns out that even
gravitational giants like black holes
occasionally run into each other in the
seemingly vast universe are you about to
see a nuclear bomb like explosion of
supersize proportions the reality might
be a little disappointing but you still
wouldn't want that galactic bomb to
detonate anywhere near your planet bear
with me here because to understand how
black holes collide you need to arm
yourself with a bit of theory black
holes come in all shapes and sizes and
of course the magnitude of the collision
would depend on which black holes are
slammed together stellar-mass black
holes are the most common type they can
have up to 20 solar masses but could fit
in a ball much smaller in diameter than
our Sun
okay now let's go back to you observing
this gravitational show first hand first
you see the two black holes getting a
little closer until they started to
orbit each other they would begin
pulling matter and gas into a vortex
between them get comfortable because it
could take billions of years for their
centers to merge but as the two black
holes merged into one they wobble a
little and then settle down into a new
bigger black hole now I hope you're not
disappointed with such an explosion-free
outcome but wait there's something I
haven't mentioned yet the excess energy
from the collision would be expelled
back into the universe as gravitational
waves as I mentioned before colliding
black holes can change the shape of the
space around them they do it by rippling
this space with gravitational waves
Albert Einstein predicted gravitational
waves over a hundred years ago but
scientists didn't observe them until
2015 when the advanced LIGO
gravitational wave Observatory finally
detected gravitational waves after eight
years of operation the cool thing about
these waves is that they affect the
distance between the Sun and the earth
they only change it by the diameter of a
hydrogen atom you'd need a whole lot of
colliding black holes to really see a
difference but what about supermassive
black holes would their collision be
more explosive these black holes have a
mass of at least hundreds of thousands
of times the mass of our Sun but the
thing is they might never even collide
at all two supermassive giants would get
close to each other until they reached a
gravitational balance and froze in their
respective orbits but add another
supermassive black hole to the equation
and the three of them could tip over the
gravitational scale and finally collide
not in a massive cosmic explosion but a
silent merger sending powerful
gravitational waves throughout the
universe you know despite the fact that
black holes are an unstoppable
insatiable force from which nothing can
escape we have nothing to fear from
their collision okay maybe if that
collision happened somewhere in the
neighborhood of our solar system then
the merging black holes would rip all
the planets in their vicinity to shreds
include
if you really want to look at a black
hole even a single black hole and not
turn into a human flavored spaghetti
noodle you need to make sure you stay a
safe distance away but that's a story
for another what if